ready to check the real housewives of
atlanta are back for Season nine not
include and you're more i think that in
the previous evenings I felt like I
didn't disappoint the fans and I don't
think they'll be disappointed to be fit
as well she got up with the star over
the phone to talk all about the dramatic
season ahead my goodness LOL it is a
beat it always delivered and this season
is going to be one of our best seasons
ever rising grab regular sex does she
look it again kicked in my hotel room
did you you didn't just mad hitting a
wall definitely go through a very
turbulent time in in our relationship
and you don't think two years my junior
to present the whole set of problems
that i've never encountered before
the man is the 29 year old who still has
if you with you know expressing himself
in a positive way
fighting dear you don't need to get into
arguments and just dealing with a woman
that is so much more seasoned and
experienced video and also successful so
it's the learning curve that's out the
window
the ride I'm a woman trying to figure
things out what what is the cause of is
you know I want to be put in a situation
where he doesn't feel comfortable and I
think it'll it all unfold on the show
and then you can make up your mind
whether or not you you would want to
root for us to stay together or apart